hey guys Peter Brown here with Cam
Robinson and you just saw Borderlands
the Pre-Sequel I did more to see it
Peter I played it I played it with these
very hands and uh yeah it was it was
really good it was really good so if you
played Borderlands 2 and you're
wondering you know like what's new for
me in the pre-sequels that was my line
well I'm taking it anyway cuz you're too
slow it's actually got a lot of good
stuff in there a lot of new stuff so
first things first Peter how do you feel
about the moon uh I know Wizards come
from the Moon and uh doesn't really have
a whole lot of gravity that's very true
and the second part is relevant to
Borderlands because you've got like you
can do jump and then you can double jump
which blasts oxygen at the back of your
suit I guess and it propels you now
that's kind of just standard that's
nothing new double jumps we've see but
you can then use that oxygen to like set
enemies on fire because there's no
atmosphere on the moon or a very very
slight atmosphere so the things will not
burn so you can use this option to burn
your enemies it's like you know a lot
about science or something I know I
should do science maybe you should think
about that anyway so you got the
anti-gravity stuff that's really cool I
also got to have hands on with I was
playing as clap Trap by the way so clap
trap didn't know he's one of the four
characters you can choose um there's
also Athena who is I can't remember
exactly her background but she's just
like a general badass then you've got um
another girl who's like a cowboy and she
can guner with two pistols and you got
willhelm who's at the beginning of
Borderlands Mustachio he's Mustachio
augmented guy but this before he
basically turned himself into a robot so
these are four characters I was Cloud
trap and um what you can do uh the
combat is mixed with the anti-gravity so
you can jump and then you can do your
classic kind of Slam attack so you play
crisis 2 you do that in crisis 2 so um
you've got a nice slam which is lots of
area of effect damage yeah um what you
can also do is you can use oxygen right
from your your suit or that are present
in bubbles actually set enemies on fire
with your fire guns so it's pretty cool
so there lots of different ways you can
use the weapons to set enemies on fire
yeah and but there you know the classic
Borderlands where you've got loads more
crazy weapons lots of new different
types powers and uh it did feel very
similar to Borderland 2 but for me
that's not a bad thing that's kind of
the point right I mean like they're
trying to give people more content and
I'm assuming they're reusing a lot of
assets apart from the setting being
different a lot of the same characters a
lot of the same things going on so in
terms of the story arc it fits in
between Borderlands one and Borderlands
2 so you're actually working for
Handsome Jack and this before Handsome
Jack kind of goes really evil we don't
need slightly evil at this point okay
and the reason why you're on the moon
you're actually there to save the people
who live on the moon but you're only
there people the moon I know who knew I
didn't know they were there they're
there we should go check that out we
should check that out we should have our
science guys on there but um you go to
the moon and you have to save it because
there's also a vault there called Elvis
and you're trying to get access to the
Vault so Elvis Presley is actually a
vault I don't know if it's Elvis pres
didn't confirm I did ask um but yeah so
there's a lot there is a lot of new
stuff in there it's not as big a jump
from Borderlands one to two right but
that's kind of because Borderland 2 was
was already pretty great right and if
you want to play it you need to have
either a PS3 or an Xbox 360 or a PC and
then uh it should work all right well
that's Borderlands Pre-Sequel stay tuned
in Gamespot for more Gamescom
coverage